[Music]
okay 1793 that's pretty high rated
opponent let's see how our opening
repertoire
fairs and we've been playing the smith
mora exclusively
we are going to continue i think the
smith more becomes more exciting at this
level because people tend to accept it
and uh play something a little bit more
conventional
the move here is if i remember correctly
for some reason i'm blanking on whether
it's bishop c4 knight f3 it is it is
knight f3 it's just to develop the other
knight
and e6 so this is one of
many possible systems but e6 in this
position
i guess we could play bishop c4 and
transpose after a6 to
one of the main lines
now generally in the smith mora this is
kind of an exception to the rule
as far as i understand from my initial
analysis you put the bishop on c4
regardless of whether black lays e6 or
not
you might say well
you know it bites on granite why would
we put it there and you have to see the
bigger picture you have to develop your
king side and castle quickly and often
the bishop actually supports a knight
sacrifice on d5
in addition it prevents black from
playing d5 easily so the bishop is doing
stuff
let's castle let's develop a6 now our
opponent is playing quite inaccurately
because
you know i've talked about this many
times the d6 square
is very important to pay attention to
in this position right
if we can get control of that square
we make it extremely difficult for black
to complete their development
for obvious reasons right it makes it
hard for black to push d6 so what's
what could be a possible move
so e5 could be a move but e5 allows d5
and our opponent is able to shove that
pawn through we should play bishop f4
developing a piece and simultaneously
controlling the d6 square knight e7
now a very logical move would be to
actually put a bishop on d6 and
establish our control over that square
we can do this in several different ways
now we can actually go e5
and
clamp down on this square even further
by shifting the knight around to e4 the
square formerly occupied by the pawn i
actually like e5 a little bit more
i feel like keeping our dark square
bishop could be valuable just if we're
ever to attack on the king side i feel
like having this bishop could be a good
idea so let's go 94. look at the control
that we have over that square black goes
d5 we on passat
now
we need to switch gears a little bit so
we've gotten control over that square
now we need to keep improving our
position somehow
and
as part of that we need to figure out
which pieces we can improve and how we
can improve them and i think there are
many ways to arrange
your pieces here
and it'll take me a second to figure out
the one that we want to
carry out i think we should play
very straightforwardly here i think we
should just go queendy to connect the
rooks
and you know the screen on d2 is very
flexible knight g6
is is not scary we can go bishop g5 to
attack black's queen
but remember to see the bigger picture
we're trying to control the d6 square by
extension we're trying to keep this pawn
well defended so we should just calmly
drop the bishop back to g3
now can somebody propose
a potential idea that exploits
the knight on g6 which is in fact quite
misplaced
yeah h4h5 is something to keep an eye on
and where should the bishop go
the way that i'm thinking about this is
okay well
the bishop has kind of done its job
on this diagonal
so from that perspective it would make
sense to bring it back to d3
on the other hand after bishop d3 black
is a very nasty move bishop b8
and it's
gotten hard to defend the e5 pawn the
advantage of playing bishop b3 is that
we open keep open the connection between
the knight and the queen so we're able
to play knight d6 in response to bishop
b8
but let me think about this bishop d3
bishop b8
we could still go knight d6 in that
position but it's not quite the same
so let's go bishop e3 let's let's keep
the queen's contact with d6 open daily
round i think for the raid
our opponent playing very quickly we
might have to speed up queen b6 i don't
like that at all it doesn't do anything
at all
this this queen is misplaced and it
leaves the king
uh wide open the only thing our opponent
might be preparing is knight d4
so let's get the rook into the game and
prevent it
and now i think everything is in place
and we can start attacking the
conclusion bishop b8 good thing we
played bishop b3
now remember something very important
just because you had planned a move in
one position doesn't mean that when the
position changes you don't have any
other defensive moves here i think we
have
a fantastic
defensive move defensive and attacking
at the same time it defends the pawn and
it assembles a piece on the king side
what am i thinking of
knight f6 checks should be considered as
well but
you know we'll re we'll leave that for
uh a different time
queen
g5 and if black goes h6 which is very
likely because our opponent is playing
quickly and superficially we shift the
queen over to h5 where it's nicely
tucked away
defending e5
i think we're in fantastic shape
and now h4 h5 is an idea that you should
be already thinking of
knight f6 check has now become far more
of a reality now that we actually have
pieces on the king side
oh gorg thank you for the prime
hopefully i'm explaining everything
relatively understandable terms
knight d6 is still possible in these
types of positions
we've got options we've got many many
options here for how to conduct the
initiative we could even play queen h5
on our own volition in order to make
room for the knight to jump into g5 okay
our opponent made us do it
black is in big trouble i'm not sure
it's totally lost but it certainly looks
that way
now to me once h6 is played this greatly
accentuates
um increases i should say the strength
of knight f6 check why is that
because after g takes f6 the pawn on h6
is capturable and it becomes an entry
point
to black's king so we can even play
queen takes h6 immediately
but we should probably prepare knight f6
we have time to do it black is so
cramped that we have time to prepare
knight f6 so we need to put a piece on a
certain square
such that after knight f6
e takes g takes f6 e takes f6 we have a
piece that's
nicely positioned for the attack now the
way that most people interpret that
question is okay well we need to play
bishop h4
we need to increase our control over the
f6 square that's not what we have to do
we don't need to control the f6 square
any more than we already are we will be
able to play knight f6
the great attacking move here's bishop
drops back to c2
in order after knight f6 to be able to
capture that knight on g6 when we want
to
does that make sense queen b8
let's calculate knight f6 gf
we're just going to play it i'm not even
i don't want to calculate this is so
overwhelming
this is so overwhelming this has to be
winning has to be yeah this is a nice
move it's nothing insane but it's a very
nice attacking move and now we reap the
benefits of that attacking move by
playing what
and this is going to end the game
immediately
what do we do yeah we take the knight we
simply take the knight fg queen takes g6
we threaten mate on h7
because we threaten mate on h7 we force
black to take the knight and after he
takes f6 there are
uh insurmount unstoppable made threats
everywhere obviously there's look at
black speed look at black's pieces i
mean our opponent just didn't do a good
job of
ever untangling and that why is that
guess what he never pushed his d-pawn
that's because we were controlling it
from the basically from the start of the
game now if you really want to be
clinical in a position like this if you
really want to attack like the greats
what should you do before playing e
takes f6
this is a no brain is something that
mathematically for sure cannot hurt it
can only help take the pawn come back to
g6
and then play e takes f6 and you're not
just trolling guess what after we do
this knight g5 has become a possibility
so after our opponent takes the pawn of
the rook which is forced we play queen
takes f6 and then knight g5 becomes okay
well he makes it easy for us
but um
but but knight g5 would have been
possible
so
let's check the theory so knight c6
knight f3 e6 yeah bishop c4 is the main
move
bishop c5 castles is the main move a6 so
there are still
15 games in the state in the position in
the database
we'll take a look so bishop f4 should
make sense to everybody
knight g7
e5 one game in the database which was
played between
in that game knight g6 happened
23 25 against the 22-28 so pretty um
pretty pretty decent players had this
position
so castles
94
bishop a7 and now we play queen d2
and moves like queen d2 are
i think very um
how should i put this let me think about
this
oftentimes you look in a position like
this and you say well
you got to do something and you were
proposing knight fg5 here
i'm sure was probably good
i'm sure it was probably good because
you want to go queen h5 and knight f6
and just destroy black
yeah maybe this was winning
faster queen h5 h6
and now um
where's the window because knight f6
check takes
takes and black is able to take the
knight in time so
it's not that simple um
pot pie dude i think you're over
simplifying this this is never as easy
as it looks
but
probably if we check with an engine
knight f25 is winning bishop takes g5
there
um
so you want to sack this and get this
bishop to f6 yeah but the problem is
remember you've sacked already two
pieces for the queen
so what black can do is say all right
i'm going to take the bishop on g5 and
then take the pawn i'm gonna have three
pieces for the queen and white doesn't
have as much of an attack now because
there's no more pieces in the attack
does that make sense so anytime you've
stacked a lot of pieces you must
remember that your opponent can
sacrifice even a queen
for
a lot of the material knight c7 also
interesting
bishop f6 knight f5 and black has these
two squares covered and his
counter-attacking white screen i'm not
convinced that this is winning for white
either
it's just unnecessary in my opinion
because we've got such control over the
position we can afford to play general
improving moves
the queen d2 knight g6 back
b5 now an important move bishop b3
bishop d3 there was bishop b8
and this pawn is very hard to defend
and if black takes this pawn then our
entire position collapses we must keep
this pawn alive in order to keep our
domination on the center
why don't we not consider bishop e2 here
should be two also was reasonable
i don't know i i honestly don't know why
we didn't play bishop b2 this was also a
very reasonable move
yeah as an alternative
i guess i was just
i don't know
kind of fixated on keeping the bishop on
this dangle to prove a point
and later on we dropped the bishop back
to c2 which was also important
queen b6 is really bad i think this is
the decisive mistake
probably our opponent had to go
at the very least complete his
development
maybe knight a5 was a better try at
least trying to harass white
but um rook 81
it should be eight and now boom queen g5
defending e5 and this is the beginning
of the end yes
this is the beginning of the end
and the game-winning move is bishop c2
and these kinds of moves they come with
a lot of experience when you are an
experienced attacker these moves come
automatically
because you understand how this works
you're like well
i know that i have to improve
the effect of knight f6 check and one of
the things that knight f6 does
is opens up this diagonal so you know
that if you had a bishop there you'd be
able to take black's knight
this is the game-winning move bishop's
two not knight f6 knight f6 is the easy
move everybody should see it
bishop c2
is the patient preparatory move prepare
fast attack sorry prepare slowly attack
fast this is a great example of that
rule once the attack begins
we're not wasting any time boom
boom boom boom everything is forced
but
what allows us to make that happen are
these slow attacking moves
so that's that's what i'll say in
conclusion in this game a pretty simple
game i i can analyze it more but i'm
pretty wiped it's late i'm gonna go to
sleep guys
thanks for hanging out everybody i hope
you had a good time
[Music]
you